We're down to just the last four days of this
campaign, but it may be more than four days
until we know the final results in every state.
And that's OK. It's a modern thing that people
even expect to know the results on Election Day.
And this year, in particular, because there are
so many mail in ballots because of the global
100 year pandemic. Roughly 80 million people
have already voted. And some states like
Pennsylvania, because they don't start
counting those mail in votes until the polls close
on Tuesday, might not have results for a few days.
And that's okay. But it's not OK for Donald Trump,
because that is exactly the window of opportunity.
He is planning on to steal this election. Here
is Donald Trump. Don't take my word for it.
Here is Trump himself saying, hopefully
we will get courts to stop the counting
of ballots that arrive after Election Day
or even just ballots that arrived on time
but weren't counted before the end of
Election Day. Here's Trump himself saying it.
Hopefully a few states remaining that want to take
a lot of time after November 3rd to count ballots
that won't be allowed by the various courts
because, as you know, we're in courts on that. We
just had a big victory yesterday in Wisconsin on
that matter. So hopefully that won't be happening.
OK, now, later on today, I'm going to talk
about how, of course, mail in ballots should
be counted after Election Day as long
as they are postmarked by Election Day.
You have the as you have until Election Day itself
to vote, you shouldn't be penalized for delays in
the mail. But the point here is that Donald Trump
is not trying to hide it. And when I've asked
Congresswoman Debbie McCaskill Powell about this,
I asked Mayor Eric Garcetti about this. I asked
Congressman Ruben Kago about this. Is Biden
ready with lawyers? They all say, yes, he is.
And that may well be true, but what if it gets to
the Supreme Court, which now has three of Donald
Trump's nominated justices on it, and they get
to decide the outcome of these ballots in this
election? Donald Trump's plan is to block
legally cast ballots from counting. That is
election fraud. That is voter suppression. That
is election suppression. It is against the law.
But they are trying to build public support
for stopping the counting of these ballots
by pretending there would be something wrong
with counting them after Election Day. This is
always the case, by the way, that this happens.
The only difference is that this time there is
more mail in ballots than ever because of the
pandemic. And Donald Trump, although now his
postmaster general says he stopped Donald
Trump's postmaster general, was interfering
with the post offices ability to handle mail.
So it might take a little bit longer. It might
actually make a difference in a couple of states
that we don't get all of the ballots counted on
election night. Now, some good news in terms
of rulings. The Supreme Court late Wednesday
said both North Carolina and Pennsylvania will be
allowed to extend their arrival deadlines for the
mail in ballots. Again, we're not changing the
postmark date. You still have to fill it out and
mail it by Election Day. But they are extending
the transit deadline essentially. Increasingly,
it really could be Pennsylvania. That is the
big one here. Pennsylvania could decide the
winner. In fact, there's lots of electoral
votes, scenarios which we will go through
where it comes down to Pennsylvania.
And secretary of pencils of the Commonwealth of
Pennsylvania, Kay Kathy Boockvar, said she expects
the overwhelming majority of votes will be counted
by Friday, November 6th. It's just a few days,
but we could actually be waiting for Pennsylvania
depending on how the election goes. I would
prefer it not be that close, but it might be.
Eight states expect to have at least 98 percent of
unofficial results by noon Wednesday. Only eight,
22 states and D.C. allow postmarked ballots to
arrive after Election Day. So the timing is going
to depend on when voters return them. New York and
Alaska aren't going to report any mail in votes
on election night. Shouldn't make a difference.
Alaska is going to Trump. New York is going very,
very powerfully to Joe Biden. Full results from
Michigan are expected to take several days.
If you combine now Pennsylvania and Michigan, you
really have many scenarios from an electoral map
standpoint where we don't know the results until
we know Michigan and Pennsylvania. If you say at
this point, what are the odds networks will
announce a president elect on election night?
I would say about 65 percent. Think there's
a 65 percent chance. It's it's not close. And
we know on election night, I think there's a 35
percent chance. We know at some point after that,
every vote must be counted. They are being
clear about their strategy. And I really
hope I know the members of Congress are telling
me Biden's got the lawyers ready. I hope he has
the right lawyers ready. I hope he has enough
lawyers ready because it's going to be a mess